plants are the basis of our food chain
plant production ensures that we have
food to eat feed for our animals and
provides us with many other items we use
daily plants are vital for biodiversity
and the natural environment and they
play a key role in the fight against
climate change which is why it's so
important to protect our native plant
life plant pests can be very destructive
and if they are not stopped they can
rapidly spread causing devastation to
the environment outbreaks of plant
diseases can badly affect people's
livelihoods too as well as the quality
and price of our food this is why we
need to act before there's a problem a
preventative approach built on import
control and surveillance of the EU
territory ensures safe trade healthy
crops and natural landscapes and reduces
the need for pesticides in response to
increasing challenges like climate
change and the growing international
trade and plants the EU is stepping up
its efforts to ensure more effective
protection of the union's plant life you
too can help do not import plants or
plant material into the EU and inform
the relevant authorities if new plant
pests are discovered together we can act
to protect plants because protecting
plants is protected
[Music]